alors que centre-ville de montréal est
presque totalement désert et les
restaurants les bars et prouve la
difficulté à attirer de la clientèle
pour remplir leur table selon un sondage
de l'association restauration québec 61
% des restaurateurs affirment qu'ils
devront fermer leurs portes
si la situation reste telle quelle après
noël comment secteur va parvenir à tenir
le coup j'en discute avec simone
chevalot qui est propriétaire du bar le
furent co du café parvis et aussi de la
buvette chez simone ce sont tous des
institutions que sont connus par les
montréalais
bonjour à cheval ou bonjour d'ailleurs
actuellement vous êtes je crois au mot
dit m me souffle à l'oreille à la
buvette chez simone
voilà exactement on attend une rumeur là
il ya peut-être également notre des
clients qui sont la première question
comment ça se passe pour vous depuis le
déconfinement des restos et ça bougeait
sans cesse
c'est vraiment s'en prenant à observer
et à essayer de jouer avec ça en fait
nous on en aurait ouvert deux premières
semaines donc les clients est au rendez
vous pour la première semaine mais de ce
qu'on comprend c'est que de semaine en
semaine entre andy malouines
c'est effectivement ce site il ya aussi
des facteurs qui interviennent qui sont
pas de vue à la pandémie qui sont dues
aux vacances de la construction
quand même toujours
une période de l'année plus calmes donc
c'est peut-être sept ans il
je me dirais que si la canicule je suis
moins leur défaveur et qualité ça ne
vous aide pas des fois des restaurants
sont climatisées on avait plutôt
l'impression inverse non non la folie
parmi les gens habitant de la canicule
fait complètement d'or n'est pas ok ok
ya certaines de vos barres comme le
furent coûts qui sont situés au centre
ville
mais actuellement aussi se passe
absolument rien au centre-ville l'art ce
n'est pas que tous il a souhaité que la
fin je ne serais pas là sa cianas
[Musique]
principalement à cause de sa
localisation qui vous entraîner les gens
sont pauvres moutons et fava y est la
rue sainte-catherine celle des as les
cartes de membres jugés actuellement
l'action de la part de la ville de
montréal dans le dossier là un monde
suffit culte et à comprendre comment s
positionner pas manquer - cc j'arrive à
leurs applications là pour nous
connaissez nous
de motiver notre équipe parce que c'est
très important d'engager des gens mais
on veut les garder
on veut en plus en plus on veut qu'ils
soient bien on veut qu'ils sentent en
sécurité ont vu le cdh plaisir donc on
essaie de faire fi un peu de six
mouvements l'eau de la ville c'est la
vie privée est-ce que vous parvenez
quand même être rentable malgré la
capacité d'accueil qui réduisent
actuellement à la grande question mais
au parvis et l'eau pour ne rien faire
donc on est en forme en fin de service
paas ans et pour les sens et ça va quand
même un petit peu en croissant à l'égard
de la buvette
nous avons des croissants mais je pense
quand on n'est pas déficitaire
parce qu'une fois des dettes
contrairement à illac terriers dans des
magazines profilant donc déjà se faire
c'est quand même assez positif mais
rentable je pourrais profiter
j'aime bien ce que vous faites quand
même quand vous pensez à être capable de
tenir donc à ce rythme là si évidemment
il n'y a pas de vaccin si elle pas
nécessairement d'amélioration la
fréquentation aussi en fait une haie et
la semence ans de salariat
ça c'est l'hymne à la plus
là si nécessaire
également aussi où le retour au travail
contrairement à la pcu alors la
subvention salariale ça aide les gens
donc les employeurs revenir au travail
pensez vous que d'autres restaurants
parce que j'imagine que vous parlez à
d'autres restaurateurs qui pourraient
disparaître également avec cette crise
sincèrement on essaie de rester
profondément non mais c'est vrai je
crois en ce besoin qu'ont les gens de
mais après c'est de savoir combien sans
saveur six mois deux ans des soutes et
ça change la donne les u13
je vous la ressentez la solidarité entre
les restaurateurs un terminal alors vous
souhaite davantage sur les rives de
solidarité est également aussi des
clients merci surtout à la mouche wallon
d'abord été avec nous